pause this video and see if you can
subtract this magenta rational
expression from this yellow one
alright now let's do this together and
the first thing that jumps out at you is
that you realize that these don't have
the same denominator and you would like
them to have the same denominator and so
you might say well let me rewrite them
so that they have a common denominator
and a common denominator that will work
will be one that is divisible by each of
these denominators so it has all of the
factors of each of these denominators
I'm lucky for us each of these
denominators are already factored so let
me just write the common denominator
I'll start rewriting the yellow
expression so you have the yellow
expression actually let me just make it
clear I'm going to write both so yellow
one and then you're going to subtract
the magenta one whoops I'm saying yellow
but drawing in magenta so you have the
yellow expression which I'm about to
rewrite actually want to make a longer
line so the yellow expression - - the
magenta one - the magenta one right over
there
now as I mentioned we want to have a
denominator that has all the common
denominator has to have be divisible by
both this yellow denominator and at this
magenta one so it's got to have the Z
plus 8 in it it's got to have the 9z
minus 5 in it and it's also got to have
both of these well already we already
accounted for the 9z minus 5 so it has
to have be divisible by z plus 6z plus 6
notice just by multiplying the
denominator by Z plus 6 we're now
divisible by both of these factors and
both of these factors because 9 Z minus
5 was a factor common to both of them
and if you were just dealing with
numbers when you were just adding and
subtracting fractions it works the exact
same way
all right so what will the numerator
become well we multiply the denominator
times Z plus 6 so we have to do the same
thing to the numerator it's going to be
negative Z to the 3rd times Z plus 6 now
let's focus over here we had well we
want the same denominator so we could
write this as Z plus 8z
e + 8 x z + 6 x times Z plus 6 times 9 Z
minus 5 and these are equivalent I've
just changed the order that we multiply
in and that doesn't change their value
and if we multiplied the so we had a 3
on top before and if we multiplied the
denominator times Z + 8 we also have to
multiply the numerator times Z plus 8 Z
+ 8 so there you go
and so this is going to be equal to this
is going to be equal to actually I'll
just make a big line right over here
this is all going to be equal to we have
our probably don't need that much space
let me see maybe that may be about that
much so I'm gonna have the same
denominator I'll just write in a neutral
color now Z plus 8 times 9 Z minus 5
times Z plus 6 so over here just in this
blue color we want to distribute this
negative Z to the 3rd negative Z to the
3rd times Z is negative Z to the 4th
negative Z to the 3rd times 6 is minus 6
Z to the 3rd and now this negative sign
right over here actually instead of
saying negative Z negative of this whole
entire thing we could just say plus the
negative of this or another way of
thinking about it you could view this as
negative 3 times Z plus 8 so we could
just distribute that so let's do it so
negative 3 times Z is negative 3z and
negative 3 times 8 is negative 24 and
there you go we are we are done we found
a common denominator and once you have a
common denominator you can just subtract
or add the numerators and instead of
viewing this as minus this entire thing
I viewed it as adding is and then having
a negative 3 in the numerator
distributing that
and then these I can't simplify it any
further sometimes you'll do one of these
types of exercises and you might have to
second degree terms or two first degree
terms or two constants or something like
that and then you might want to add or
subtract them to simplify it but here
these are all have different degrees so
I can't simplify it any further and so
we are all done